heute sprechen wir über die worte
komisch lustig und witzig diese drei
worte sind alle sehr ähnlich
aber es gibt auch wichtige unterschiede
die man wissen muss
denn man kann sie leicht verwechseln
der größte unterschied ist witzig lustig
sind fast immer positiv
im englischen übersetzt man witzig und
lustig mit fanny komisch hingegen hat
häufig eine negative bedeutung
man kann komisch im englischen auch mit
fanny übersetzen aber meistens übersetzt
man es mit ort oder strange hier sind
zwei beispiele aus unseren kommentaren
mohammed mamduh schreibt zu super easy
german nummer 50 janisch ist ein geiler
schauspieler komisches video und grazie
schreiben zu super easy german 48 sehr
komisch und hilfreich danke offenbar
meinen mohammed und grazie leaders
positiv aber für einen muttersprachler
klingt das so dynamisch ist great actor
strange video very strange and help for
the cure also ihr seht wo das problem
ist merkt euch das englische fanny ist
auf deutsch witzig oder lustig das
englische strange ist auf deutsch
komisch hier seht ihr jetzt ein paar
beispiele
[Gelächter]
janisch hat einen witz gelesen
der witz scheint sehr witzig zu sein
denn er hört nicht auf zu lachen
[Gelächter]
hast du das neue video von stefano
gesehen
ja das war ziemlich witzig wie katy
magst du deutsche comedy geht so das
meiste finde ich ehrlich gesagt nicht so
lustig janus erzählt jetzt einen witz
warum bucht eine blondine keinen nonstop
flug weil sie angst hat nie wieder
aussteigen zu können ja nicht das ist
überhaupt nicht lustig ihr seht lustig
und witzig sind austauschbar im
deutschen sie bedeuten fast das gleiche
komisch hingegen ist ein bisschen anders
das ist eine komische statue
ich weiß gar nicht was sie bedeuten soll
so was wie ein komischer film
ich habe überhaupt nicht verstanden
worum es geht
was so ein komisches wetter heute
erstmals warm dann hörst geregnet
jetzt ist es richtig kalt was sind das
für komische kritzeleien
das doch nicht
was hast du denn für komische klamotten
an
komisch es ist doch witzig hier nur bier
kaufen
[Musik]
und während jan ich jetzt wir kaufen
geht könnt ihr noch übungen machen und
gucken ob wir das richtig verstanden
habe wann man witzig lustig und komisch
sagt das ganze geht diese woche bei uns
bei ketzin wir haben die übungen schon
online eingeben und ihr könnt sie dort
lösen werdet einfach in pöttsching dann
bekommt ihr einen link um die übung zu
machen
hier könnt ihr unseren kanal abonnieren
danke fürs zuschauen und bis zur
nächsten woche
jetzt gehen wir trinken
jetzt gehen wir drücken die stücke okay
ich habe mit